let's take this on this new language and
start to put it in forms he already know
because you've actually been dealing
with functions for our long time just to
having realize them okay
for instance inputs and outputs
increasing outputs the classic name the
classy labels we give to our influence
and outputs ah x and y right X is
usually out input and Y is usually our
output okay so what you've got here is Y
as a function of X Y as a function of X
so the way I write that is like so Y is
a function of X okay so like I said
we're repurposing all notation of these
brackets for this new purpose yeah we'll
talk about when you start to reverse
things in some cases yes but in some
cases and in fact this example we might
not do it today because at the time but
in this example no in fact only for this
example why is that we will explain okay
now um Y is the function of X now they
haven't given you any like you know
markings or anything like that I have no
idea where this is let's just for the
sake of our understanding let's just
slap some numbers on here okay so for
instance if that was negative one and
that was two what might the equation of
this parabola be what might it be
Scott R it's at negative 1 into so when
you factorized it the factorization
would have been something like X plus 1
that's what would give you the solution
and X minus 2 that would have given you
both these roots so just play pretend
with me
let's just write that in okay so what
does this notation mean right why isn't
just another number it's the name of a
function that has X's in it ok so this
is my function and my name for it is why
that's the label I'm putting on ok now I
think with me does this this is
fit our definition of more facility to
fit the definition of a relation yeah it
does
these numbers are completely linked
together right if you notice something
about Y you'll know something about X
let's think about the next thing is it a
function does each input have exactly
one output does each careful does each
uh this is does each X have exactly one
y hmm now let's just do a bit of an
experiment okay let's think about some
of the X's it's taken X for instance if
I take an X like x equals minus one x
equals minus one what kinds of values
could I possibly have what kind of
options are there for x equals minus one
the answer is there's only one option
right when you put x equals minus one
into here this turns into zero I don't
care what this is anymore it'll be zero
which is why it's a root okay for this
particular one let's try another value
how that x equals zero that's an input
what output might I get from that it
makes equal zero looks to me when I put
in here it'll become 0 plus 1 which is 1
times 0 minus 2 which is negative 2
that's just negative 2 how many outputs
have I got for my one input answer I've
just got one output right when I come
over here at 2 I happen to get the same
output but that's okay I only get one
every input in fact has exactly one
output what would it look like if it
didn't well as it happens I have one on
the board right I'm gonna skip this
middle one for a second because a bit
more have a look at this circle down
here okay let's just make up some
numbers
let's coin this let's be booty boy 1 1
minus 1 minus 1 what's the equation of
that circle
x squared plus y squared equals it's the
unit circle isn't it okay now take a
number take an input i'd say x equals 0
x equals 0 there's an easy important
take what happened do you get when you
pop x equals 0 into here let's just
actually Chris them it misses no hard
right I'm going to get 0 squared plus y
squared with 1 you see I've just done a
straight substitution okay with that
that's I can ignore him when I say Y
squared equals 1
what's the solution to that I take
squaring both sides right because it's
squared there are two numbers I can
square right also minus one and you can
see where they are in fact plus or minus
one you see that one input provides me
two outputs right do you see what's
going wrong here so this guy there's
still a relationship you there's still a
connection between the XS and the Y's
makes this beautiful shape here right
but it's not a function there isn't just
one output for each input okay
sometimes you do get one output can you
see there are two spots on the circle
where I get exactly one where are they
where are they what values of X give me
a any one this spot here x equals one
that's only got one solution and x
equals negative one also has only one
solution but even though there are some
spots where the input has one output I
want every single spot to have one
important one output okay so therefore
this is not a function it's still a
relation it's just not this special kind
of relation we're focusing on at the
moment this guy on the other hand this
is a function
okay last one for the easiest on
philosophy have a look at the middle one
now using your intuition does it seem
like a function or not think about
putting in some inputs we'll finish this
and then you can have up by putting a
value like x equals zero I'm going to
get that value whatever it is one output
if I put in a value like this x equals
whatever that RIT is I'll get y equals
zero again one output it works okay so
my conclusion is here's a nice easy way
to remember if you take your graph and a
vertical line okay and you place your
vertical line across the graph like say
there if what you have is a function
then wherever you move your vertical
line here or here or I'm destroying my
grass or here huh right then you get one
output one point of intersection have a
look at my second what happened I got
two it's not a function okay we call
that a vertical line test we're gonna
continue looking at it on Thursday